once we started looking at that in that
way it wasn't like finding a news
article that said file a class action
against some company it was finding a
lot of information clustering it
together to find an event and then
understanding what was the legal value
of that specific event right
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
hello and welcome to another episode of
20 minute leaders this is a very very
special episode it is being released
with some really amazing announcements
about this company meet evie talbot
narcy co-founder and ceo of dero ai
aviatago or evia is the co-founder and
ceo of darrow an ai startup on a mission
to uncover injustice evia served as a
combat officer in a special unit of the
idf and later on went to study law and
cognitive science at the hebrew
university of jerusalem he clerked at
the israeli supreme court for justice
uzi vogelman where he met co-founder
ellar spiegelman elvia is also one of
the founders of yahov an israel youth
movement for social change teaching
young activists about the democratic
values of zionism
aviator nazi welcome to 20 minute
leaders
thanks thanks for having me it is um
quite unique that i get so excited about
a company
i am honored to be a small part of it
from from the get-go but just
understanding what you're doing and
following your journey
and not just what you're doing but the
social impact journey that you're on
doing it in a very non-conventional way
that that's really inspiring and that's
what i want to talk to you about in
these 20 minutes i want to understand
you better i want to understand darrow
better and how you're using deep
technology to make significant changes
in the world where technology didn't
really exist before
yeah well
first of all again thanks for having me
but i think like
the issue with doing something inspiring
or something like that i think we just
started out with trying to do something
right um we we were looking at this
world where a lot of legal violations
existed
issues where companies or corporations
were harming a lot of people
by doing something illegal
like privacy breaches or environmental
acts that were polluting or
contaminating the environment
and and we were thinking about that and
saying like
gosh how many cases are there in the
world
that are never detected and never really
reached court
it it it shocked us um and then once we
saw that then we said well
maybe this is a dramatic moment we
should change the way that we're
thinking about this so
it all came to be when i met alad my
co-founder and ceo at
um
we met together in law school actually
he interviewed me to the law review wow
um and and he made that mistake of
accepting me and okay um but once he
accepted me then then we got to that
position where we were thinking about
the same problems kind of like he's this
like macroeconomics guy you know
and um we thought about a lot of
problems that were like near to the
justice area right um now is this in the
context of starting a company so you're
in law school
it's not that traditional for somebody
who's in law school to be thinking about
problems at a scale of what a startup
might look at them is that the intention
that the two of you are engaging already
no i i really wanted to be like a public
attorney
wow i i really didn't think about like
starting a startup at all and i think
allah didn't as well we did have some
thoughts about the world of tech and how
law wasn't like progressing enough
but it wasn't that we were thinking
about starting a company and we like
the best evidence for the fact that we
weren't was that we both went to clerk
for the same supreme court justice like
on the track to being lawyers right um
and and we both became lawyers we both
took the bar and we both worked as
lawyers um but during our time in court
i think there was one like
point where everything changed like that
singularity point right um where i
brought a whiteboard into our like
office we had an office together we
would sit about 16 hours a day together
um
i i think today i have more hours with
the lad than his wife yell sometimes so
we got really close and then
we started looking at that white board
and everything that we were seeing in
court
was like we would see
many cases a day and we would dismiss
most of them
but on the outside when you just sit on
a break and look at your phone you're
like
there are a lot of legal violations
they're untreated they don't get to
court ever most victims of the illegal
action don't really get their day in
court right and so
we had that thought of like these cases
should come to court somehow we started
drawing
on the whiteboard
the problems what are the bottlenecks
what what's making like those cases
outside that information not get to
court to the supreme court right there's
a lot of instances in the way
um
and once we met gila we understand
that this was like a problem of
intelligence gathering so gila is this
cesar cto um
genius she's a genius yeah she's a
genius and and when we meet her i think
she was 24 at the time she just got like
released from the army she was a
software developer and data scientist uh
she was in the ram course before that
and then got to the a200 unit when we
were in the officers academy together
yeah yeah exactly so
we meet gila and and she's like i like
this idea because i have the feeling
that it's going to like a social impact
kind of place and that's the kind of
startup she wanted to do so we got
connected over ideology but at some
point we start talking and we understand
that there may be a technological
solution for the problem here
um so so we start working on something
that was very primitive um but it was
this data pipeline that allowed us to
find new information about cases that
were never brought to court right um and
when i mean a case then the first thing
that we saw was like this huge data
breach a massive data breach in israel
that just no one sued over
so why is that how do you explain a
situation
it's 2021
all these tech companies they obviously
have all these personal information
about us there's no real control over
how they're being disseminated and we're
observing that we have data breaches and
obviously this is illegal
why aren't we seeing it in court where's
the bottleneck so we thought the
bottleneck at the get-go we thought the
bottleneck was
that people were not seeing the
information
then later on we learned that it wasn't
that the evidence wasn't online and it
wasn't that people were not seeing it
they were just seeing bits and pieces of
it
the problem is that you don't have like
no one's shouting at you a coherent
factual story saying
this company had a data breach in this
state and that's wrong because of that
law and therefore it should be sued
there's no information like that out
there
what you really get is a url with some
information about the company in some
place and another url where you see oh
they just released this product and
another url where you know oh this
product doesn't have a password gate and
another url where there's some
information about the problems of the
data and how sensitive it is and and
combining all that information together
fusing that data from different data
sources getting to one factual story
that's coherent and people could
actually read and take action upon that
was the problem once we started looking
at that in that way it wasn't like
finding a news article that said file a
class action against some company it was
finding a lot of information clustering
it together to find an event and then
understanding what was the legal value
of that specific event right
that makes a lot of sense now if we look
a little bit broader
and we're looking at darrow as you know
with the vision you know how many how
many people are you daryl today we're 43
today holy crap 43 today i think when we
met it must have been like 10 or 15.
yeah unbelievable yeah
where's the vision at well if you're
looking at the legal word endearo and
the social world where are you headed
yeah so
well i do want to say that like
on the legal side of things we started
looking and said like we don't want to
be another legal tech company we don't
want to make the process that attorneys
are going through um in their day-to-day
lives more efficient we want to bring
justice to the world
that was the vision so
simple yeah it sounds simple right so
the vision for us is creating a world of
frictionless justice we were looking at
the world
and saying like wait
we have people people are electing
officials these officials are making law
and that law is supposed to spill on
reality it's supposed to become reality
but to do that you need enforcement
we don't have enforcement it's not
optimized at all right so we want to
optimize that justice economy to make it
so that we actually get all the cases
that should be filed to court to court
and we get them resolved as fast as we
can so the mission for darrow is to find
every legal violation and resolve it
that's what we're doing today and and
the methods that we're using are methods
of building a data platform for lawyers
for litigation professionals that can
actually use that platform to source new
cases share them inside the firm and
then take them to court and act upon
them and also like the major thing that
we we discovered during this is that
you need to underwrite these cases you
can't just like
bring someone a case right you need to
actually tell them what's the action
going to bring here what
can you quantify justice in a sense so
you want to tell them this is the damage
caused to people this is the probability
of success in court based on previous
case law and this is what you're going
to make in some kind of probability
if you show that to attorneys and you
get them enough cases they can make
their model more stable and they could
bring in a steady stream of cases to the
firm and i imagine that until now the
real way to do this would have been
intuition people that have had you know
years of experience with seeing perhaps
hundreds of legal cases while he along
comes there and now you're seeing you
know thousands or hundreds of thousands
of cases and you're able to then make
the quantify the potential outcome
versus also the probability or chances
of success
where's the impact side going into this
so how so you know well going back to
gila's motivation to come here what what
is that about so
the the north star for daryl is how much
money we bring to victims right we want
to make it so that victims of illegal
action
get back what it is that
was taken from them it could be
well-being right right it could be that
that someone took your right to to live
with clean air or clean water but it
could also be money that was actually
taken from you uh whether it is that you
bought a product and didn't get it or
got like a defective product it doesn't
really matter but the issue is that we
want to get that money back to you or
that well-being back to you and the way
to quantify that in a capitalistic
society is money right so we're
measuring how much like fraudulent
transactions if you will we're
discovering on the market and how much
many of them are we getting to attorneys
that could do something about it right
um once we get the case to court then we
also help the company or the law firm in
a sense we help them build their case
and get it
resolved as fast as possible through the
data platform yeah through the data
platform and through our actuarial
support of settlements
right that makes a lot of sense now
this episode is going to go out after a
lot of the a lot of the great
announcements so i'm going to allow
myself to talk a little bit about that
and the growth of the company you're
mentioning that untraditionally you
started you kind of started daryl
without knowing that you're going to
start a company you sort of came
together with a lot and you ideated
through what are the bottlenecks and
then you realize that okay there's
actually an opportunity and then along
comes gila and and and brings the
technology side and you're building a
great company what is the north star for
you as a ceo
as you're entering the towers every
morning and you're opening the office
where where are you at
so
i think when like some introduction to
this uh
both aladdin i and and also gila
actually we got into this whole world
through this
um thought of how we look at people and
what kind of corporation do we want to
build what kind of company
and when we looked at that we we sat
together on the beach i think it was
august 2020. wow we thought about a
company that was going to be
human-centric in the sense that
we want to like our mission in the world
is to find every legal violation and
resolve it why do you solve legal
violations why do you want to bring
justice to the world it's because you
think that with justice people could be
their selves could be whoever they
really want to be and and be the authors
of that life story that they're telling
and we thought well we're going to do
this in the outside right we're going to
help victims of illegal actions resolve
their problems and live the life want
tell their story but we also want our
employees at darrow we want darylers to
tell their life story and in that sense
i think my mission as a ceo is to make
sure that the employees at daryl are a
hundred percent into telling their own
life story they're authentic they bring
themselves to to the place of work and
and they live a life that they're happy
about if that's true then i think
everything will be true like sales
marketing um we'll get the number of
cases that we want production would be
good r d would be good engineering
everything would be amazing if everyone
at daryl were feeling that they could be
the real self and they were on this
dramatic kind of journey into their
lives and all those journeys combined
all their stories are the daryl's story
right our stories are our story
how do you measure that kpi how do you
go to sleep at night knowing that i am
building a company whose culture is
human-centric bottom-up approach for you
know for justice within darrow how do
you how do you even go about resolving
okay am i actually doing a good job here
it's hard
first of all i'm not sure that i have
like one kpi that could really be
the best for this
it's hard to find one um when we tried
to quantify it in the first like
iteration here then we said something
like let's check the net promoter score
we'll ask employees uh exactly one more
square of zero within there yeah within
daryl we'd ask
would you recommend uh um darrow as a
place of work for a friend right
um and and we ask that and we get
results from that and and they're high
of course and that's how i know that
things are going in the right direction
but i think the major thing that that we
need to do is
discuss this discuss our culture and
make sure that people from within are
building it and not like this top-down
approach of building a culture where
we want every event we want every value
to be
manifested
by the employees at daryl we want people
to build what it is that we're doing
here in the sense that they feel
ownership on culture i think a lot of
the time when i talk to like fellow ceos
fellow c-level people from from
companies culture is is discussed as
this leadership issue right and and we
don't believe that we have we had an
offsite like two weeks ago for
for the executives and our thought was
like let's talk about culture
the conversation started with everyone
in the room agreeing that we can't make
any decisions about culture if we could
talk about it it's nice that we could
decide about a lot of other things as
executives at daryl but we can never
decide anything about culture without
everyone that's involved being a part of
the decision right deciding things about
a company's culture means that you are
the culture because you're building that
story and we want everyone to bring
their own story into that terror story i
love it
take me back a little bit about evia i
want to learn a little bit more about
you yeah sure um born raised in israel
grew up in uh in herzliya but actually
in in the nearby kibbutz
um and i was like this yelled hoots an
outsider kid in the kibbutz so that
usually means that
you get the feeling of
um
you're different from from your peers
but also you come from a different
culture so
my parents were capitalist pigs and and
the people at the kibbutz were
some sort of socialist
um of course it has changed uh uh right
within years but but yeah definitely
this this like
differentiation between the places that
i grew up in that duality that normative
duality of two types of of social
structures brought me to think about
social structures like very early on and
i was a very annoying child i think by
the age of five or six i would ask a lot
of annoying questions
that made me
i think into the person i am today and
you can see how that transforms into law
right 100 and the whole reason that we
were the keyboards for the first place
was that um
my parents were both in the military and
they needed someone to take care of the
kids until late at night so when when my
my father retired from the army a few
years after we just went back to the
city and and started studying there
and and that was something entirely else
because you would think that you go back
home right you're from the city so now
you you go back to the city and
everyone's supposed to accept you as
part of it
but still there's something about that
that people feel like well you're from
the kibbutz you didn't study with us
earlier um and and that difference made
it so that i understood that that
outsider position was something that i
would hold for a long time
um and then i went to the army i went to
givati
and and same happened there most of my
team were religious so we had this like
uh issue of also being like the the guys
that were secular right had that feeling
of okay we are
we are part of another culture right
we're the minority here which is funny
because mostly in israel secular people
are not the minority um and then that
brought me again to think about culture
and inclusiveness and then i was i had
the privilege of being a part of
the founding team of of a unit called
ramon um i i got there a bit after it
was founded and and had the chance of
building the culture there as well and
that was also something that taught me a
lot about being included being part of
the unit and uh i think we can do a
whole episode just on the funding of
raymond this isn't yeah it was it was
amazing this was a desert commando unit
um in the border of sinai it was very
interesting
the operational uh things were
interesting but also i think building a
culture there was interesting and yeah i
can talk about it for hours and then
later on um i went to study law and
cognitive science and i fell in love
with law
but it also reminded me a lot of tech
because law had that promise of
authorship of your own life story right
we'll give you all your rights and
you'll just decide who you want to be
and you'll be free to be whoever and and
tech had like information technology had
the same kind of promise at that time i
grew up on windows 95 and it was all
about that right it was like we'll line
up all the windows for you and you'll
decide who you want to be um and it took
me a few months to see that because of
the interference of capital
both promises were not really real um
law was being controlled and still is
controlled by capital
and so a lot of the people that don't
have enough money just don't get to
whatever it is that
it seems to be justice for them um there
is this justice gap which is a capital
gap and the same goes for tech like tech
had like for most companies they had
these consumer propositions which were
amazing but during the life of the
company
capital starts interfering and then
the proposition changes a bit and shifts
from
helping the consumer and the user be
empowered to
changing their life in a way that was
controlling and and not giving them the
authorship of their own life story so i
i thought of ways to mitigate this and
after two years of researching um i
found a lot and he helped me take it to
a different place and i thought i think
that's how we got to daryl in a sense we
were thinking about how to use law to
regulate tech in a sense but then we
thought of it in the other way around
the other way around let's use tech to
build up law to to make good on its
promise of helping people be the authors
of their own life story right i love it
i just love it
if you had to
think of how other people
would look at evia how would they
describe you in a few words if i were to
ask ella or gila or any other 40
darrowers who's evia what would they say
i think the the the like for darwers it
would be
weird
that that would be the word
um we use in hebrew we use yet
sure
um so i definitely am a weird person uh
i also think i'm a hopeless romantic wow
i i i haven't heard that before and i
love it i i believe in what we're doing
like from within
and that makes me into uh someone that's
susceptible to
uh be disappointed when something bad
happens and to be extremely happy when
something good happens so i could like
for me that roller coaster of
founding the startup is it's personal
and it happens like every day right
every day when something goes bad or
something goes good that then i have
those feelings and
they're strong and i think like it's a
life worth living you want to live a
life where you you really get like
strong feelings about everything so yeah
i think that that would be another word
romantic sounds like you sleep well at
night
no i not
not most of them but for different
reasons yeah for different for different
reasons yeah yeah definitely
it's so interesting and inspiring
and i just i love these stories of
leveraging tech to in this case bring
justice but to literally make the world
better i mean it's a nice phrase that
people like to put out there but then
what you're talking about the
quantifiably being able to measure and
having
a succinct kpi
that their wars can sort of have as a
guiding north star helping victims and
seeing how are you actually translating
your work into helping them tell their
story i think that's that's an amazing
piece so thank you very very much thank
you for having me
hmm